JUDGE ADVISED THEM TO REMAIN
ANONYMOUS FOR A LONG TIME.
>> PAULA REID, THANK YOU.
LET'S BRING IN NATASHA.
SHE ACCUSED TRUMP OF ASSAULTING
HER AT MAR-A-LAGO WHILE SERVING
AS A JOURNALIST FOR "PEOPLE"
MAGAZINE.
IF IT'S OKAY FOR ME TO CALL YOU
THAT, THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
WHAT'S YOUR REACTION TO THE
VERDICT?
>> I'M ELATED AND VERY EMOTIONAL
ABOUT THIS.
IT'S BEEN AN EMOTIONAL WEEK.
AND I DIDN'T EXPECT THE JURY TO
HAVE A RESPONSE SO FAST.
I I DIDN'T KNOW WHAT THAT WAS
GOING TO MEAN.
AND WHEN HEARD THE NEWS, I GOT
TO TELL YOU, I WAS JUMPING UP
AND DOWN.
>> I IMAGINE PART OF IT WAS
BECAUSE YOU TOLD YOUR STORY TO
THEM AND THEIR BELIEVED YOU.
THAT MUST HAVE BEEN SOME OF WHAT
YOU WENT THROUGH.
>> VERY MUCH SO.
FOR MANY OF US WHO CAME FORWARD
IN 2016, IT'S BEEN A LONG ROAD.
THERE'S A THE LOT OF PEOPLE THAT
DON'T BELIEVE OUR STORIES.
TO GET THE STORY UNDER OATH AND
TO HAVE A JURY BELIEVE IT IS A
VERY HEARTWARMING, VINDICATING
FEELING.
JUST A FEELING OF HOPE THAT WHEN
YOU TELL THE TRUTH, YOU CAN BE
BELIEVED.
>> YOU'RE ONE OF MORE THAN A
DOZEN WOMEN WHO MADE SUCH
ALLEGATIONS AGAINST THE FORMER
PRESIDENT.
WHAT LED YOU INTO THAT
COURTROOM?
I'M NOT SURE IF YOU'RE
COMFORTABLE TALKING ABOUT IT,
BUT HOW DID YOU COME TO BE ONE
OF THE WOMEN TESTIFYING THAT
DAY?
>> HER TEAM ASKED ME IF WOULD.
I THINK THE BELIEF WAS THAT I
HELPED SHOW A PATTERN.
AND THAT IT WOULD BE HELPFUL FOR
THE JURY TO HEAR THAT.
AND WHEN THEY ASKED ME, I JUST
THOUGHT IT'S SOMETHING THAT I
HAD TO DO.
>> WAS IT DIFFICULT?
>> IT WAS DIFFICULT LEADING UP
TO IT.
ONCE I GOT ON TO THE STAND, I
JUST FELT LIKE IT WAS ME AND THE
JURY AND I WAS TELLING THEM WHAT
HAPPENED.
EVERYTHING ELSE AROUND ME JUST
DISAPPEARED.
IT WAS LIKE THIS STRANGE ZEN
MOMENT OF TRUTH, WHERE I WAS
FINALLY TELLING IT IN AN AREA
THAT WAS VERY SERIOUS AND
IMPORTANT.
AND NOTHING ELSE MATTERED.
SO THE DIFFICULTIES DISAPPEARED
ONCE I GOT ON THE STAND.
>> THIS IS KIND OF A DIFFICULT
QUESTION.
BUT DO YOU THINK IT'S THAT
PEOPLE DON'T BELIEVE YOU OR YOU
THINK THE PEOPLE WHO VOTE FOR
DONALD TRUMP ANY WAY JUST DON'T
CARE?
>> IT'S A COMBINATION OF BOTH.
THEY HEAR NEGATIVE VIEWS ABOUT
THE WOMEN THAT WERE LIARS.
THEY DON'T BELIEVE.
THEN THERE'S A CERTAIN GROUP
THAT THINK IT PROBABLY HAPPENED
AND DON'T CARE.
THAT'S REALLY THE MOST
HEARTBREAKING TO ME.
>> AND AS SOMEBODY WHO WAS
ASSAULTED BY DONALD TRUMP FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY UNDER OATH, WHAT
IS IT LIKE TO SEE HIM LEADING IN
THE POLLS NOT JUST FOR THE
PRESIDENTIAL NOMINATION, BUT
MOST RECENTLY IN A "WASHINGTON
POST" POLL LEADING AGAINST JOE
BIDEN.
TALKING ABOUT WHAT YOU
EXPERIENCED AND WHAT SO MANY
OTHER WOMEN HAVE TESTIFIED UNDER
OATH ABOUT THEIR EXPERIENCES
WITH HIM ASSAULTING YOU?
>> WELL, FIRST, I'M NEVER QUITE
SURE ANYMORE WHAT TO BELIEVE
WHEN WE HEAR ABOUT POLLS.
SO I DON'T TAKE IT TOO
SERIOUSLY.
AND I DO HOLD ON TO HOPE THAT
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE HAVE LEARNED
A LOT OVER THE LAST FOUR AND
SIE
SIX
SKBREERZ WILL MAKE A WISER
CHOICE IN 2024 THAN IN 2016.
I HAVE HOPE FOR THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
>> IT'S A BRAVE THING TO COME
FORWARD TO TELL A STORY ABOUT AN
ASSAULT, AND IT'S A BRAVE THING
TO DO SO BEFORE A JURY.
IT'S A BRAVE THING TO DO SO
RIGHT NOW.
SO I THANK YOU AND I THANK YOU
FOR WHAT YOU'RE DOING NOT JUST
FOR JUSTICE IN YOUR CASE, BUT
ALL THE GIRLS AND WOMEN WHO
DON'T DESERVE TO BE ASSAULTED
OUT THERE.
>> THANKS, JAKE.
>> APPRECIATE IT.
>>> HERE TO DISCUSS IS LAURA
COATES.
ALSO JOINING US IS A FORMER
FEDERAL PROSECUTOR.
QUICK VERDICT BY THE JURY.
EVEN SURPRISING DONALD TRUMP'S
ATTORNEY, WHAT DID YOU MAKE OF
THAT?
>> IT CERTAINLY SUGGESTS THAT
THE JURY FOUND THE EVIDENCE VERY
COMPELLING.
AND I REALLY THINK TRUMP AND HIS
TEAM ARE TO BLAME FOR THAT.
HE DID NOT TESTIFY.
HE WAS NOT EVEN PRESENT FOR THE
TRIAL.
SO REALLY I THINK THEY MADE THIS
JOB VERY EASY FOR THE JURY AND
SO I'M NOT SURPRISED THEY
REACHED THAT VERDICT.
>> DOES IT UNDERMINE THE ATTEMPT
TO TRY TO GET DONALD TRUMP AN
APPEAL, THE FACT THAT THEY
REALLY DIDN'T STAGE MUCH OF A
DEFENSE.
>> IN THE CIVIL WORLD, HE'S NOT
REQUIRED TO TESTIFY OR APPEAR.
AND HE WAS VERY COUNTERINTUITIVE
TO ANYONE THAT COULD BE ACCUSED
OF ASSAULT IN THIS CATEGORY.
BUT HE'S NOT REQUIRED TO DO SO.
SO HIS ABSENCE IS NOT GOING TO
BE THE REASON HE WILL SAY THE
JURY DID NOT GIVE MY CLIENT A
FAIR SHOT.
THAT WAS HIS CHOICE TO DO SO.
THE MORE FERTILE GROUNDS TO
ACTUALLY APPEAL WOULD BE ON THE
AREA OF TESTIMONY THAT WAS
ALLOWED TO BE HEARD BY THE JURY.
THEY HEARD THE CATEGORY OF PRIOR
BAD EVIDENCE.
IF YOU REMEMBER FROM THE COSBY
TRIAL, THAT WAS A CRIMINAL
CONTEXT.
IT WAS A LOT ABOUT HOW AND WHO
COULD TESTIFY ABOUT THINGS THAT
WERE ALLEGED TO HAVE HAPPENED
THAT WERE NOT CHARGED OUTSIDE OF
THE CONTEXT OF THESE SPECIFIC
ALLEGATIONS.
IT WAS MORE THAN ONE PERSON WHO
WAS ALLOWED TO TESTIFY, AS YOU
JUST INTERVIEWED AS WELL ABOUT
THIS VERY NOTION.
SO THE IDEA OF WHETHER THAT WAS
UNDULY PREJUDICE SHL IS GOING TO
BE THE REAL QUEST OF AN APPEAL
IN THIS MATTER.
HE'S ALLUDED TO POSSIBLY LOOKING
AT THE JURY POOL BEING TAINTED.
IF THERE'S SOME BASIS UNDER THE
PRINCIPLES TO SUGGEST THAT THEY
DID NOT HAVE AN UNBIASSED JURY
OR REASON TO BELIEVE THEY WERE
BIASSED, THAT WOULD BE THE RIGHT
GROUND.
BUT OTHER THAN THAT, NOT MUCH TO
STAND ON.
>> SO I THINK IT'S FAIR TO SAY
THAT E. JEAN CARROLL'S CASE WAS
NOT A SLAM DUNK.
SHE DENY KNOW THE YEAR IT TOOK
PLACE.
THERE WERE OTHER QUESTIONS THAT
THEY WERE ABLE TO BRING UP.
I THINK DONALD TRUMP MADE E.
JEAN CARROLL'S CASE EASIER WITH
HIS TAIL LIGHT.
I WANT TO RUN A PIECE OF HIS
DEPGS WHEN HE'S ASKED ABOUT THE
TAPE FROM 2006, WHERE HE CLAIMED
THAT PEOPLE LIKE HIM, STARS
COULD GRAB WOMEN BY THEIR
GENITALS BECAUSE THEY ARE SO
FAMOUS.
HERE'S PART OF THAT DEPOSITION
AND WE'LL GET YOUR REX ON THE
OTHER END.
>> IN THIS VIDEO, I JUST START
KISSING THEM.
IT'S LIKE A MAGNET.
JUST KISS.
I DON'T EVEN WAIT.
WHEN YOU'RE A STAR, THEY LET YOU
DO IT.
YOU CAN DO ANYTHING.
THAT'S WHAT YOU SAID.
>> HISTORICALLY, THAT'S TRUE
WITH STARS.
>> TRUE WITH STARS THAT THEY CAN
GRAB WOMEN?
>> IF YOU LOOK OVER THE LAST
MILLION YEARS, THAT'S BEEN LARGE
LY TRUE.
NOT ALWAYS, BUT LARGELY TRUE.
UNFORTUNATELY OR FORTUNATELY.
>> YOU CONSIDER YOURSELF TO BE A
STAR?
>> I THINK YOU CAN SAY THAT,
YEAH.
>> SO JUST TO UNDERLIE THIS, HE
SAYS THAT STARS LIKE HIM CAN GET
AWAY WITH SEXUALLY ASSAULTING
WOMEN.
UNFORTUNATELY OR FORTUNATELY.
THAT MUST HAVE JUST BEEN A GIFT
TO E. JEAN CARROLL'S CASE, DON'T
YOU THINK?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
IT'S ABSOLUTELY GREAT FOR THE
DEFENSE.
IF THAT WAS FULL OF HIM TALKING
ABOUT HOW TORTURED HE FELT THAT
SOMEONE WOULD ACCUSE HIM OF THAT
BECAUSE HE WOULD NEVER DO
ANYTHING OF THAT SORT, HE CAN'T
IMAGINE THAT, IT WOULD BE ONE
THING.
THAT'S WHAT YOU'D EXPECT
SOMEBODY TO REACT TO SOMETHING
LIKE THAT.
BUT SOMEBODY LIKE DONALD TRUMP,
HE REVEALED SOMETHING TO THE
JURY, WHICH IS HE'S NOT BOTHERED
BY THIS CONCEPT.
HE NOT ONLY IS SAYING THE
S
"ACCESS HOLLYWOOD" TAPE IS
SOMETHING I SAID LONG AGO AND
DIDN'T REALLY BELIEVE AND FEEL
HORRIBLE.
HE WAS DEFENDING IT SAYING IT'S
ABSOLUTELY TRUE.
AND I DON'T KNOW HOW YOU CAN SAY
ANYTHING IS FORTUN